cool I don't know if you guys can tell
by looking at me or just my general
demeanor but I am NOT an alpha male I'm
not an alpha I'm not even a beta I'm
like three before Omega like I've been
called a little punk to my face before
I'd be like well that's your opinion
that's in fact I know I'm lucky to be a
millennial cuz I've been born even
tinker's earlier I wouldn't have lived
this long I know that cuz I was in
Louisiana for ten minutes before I let a
possum climb me alright it was just
coming right at man by the time I rose
was like a little squirrel that wanted
to play or something was hanging off my
belt I don't know who the possum the
face and person before but its face is
an actual demon it's most horrifying
thing you can have hanging off your
crotch and I'm trying to hump it off as
hard as I can just bend my knees it
didn't because I want to touch everybody
knows you touch a positive get bit by
possible you become a possum that's just
science so I'm trying to hump it off but
it climbs onto my shoulder in church my
ear and not the cute Pocahontas like he
was like and then my friend slap off my
shoulder and saved my life have you ever
had your life saved when the stakes were
incredibly low
I'll tell you guys this cuz we're family
I don't know if I believe in evolution
anymore when I mean by that is I believe
in evolution up until this point but I
think we're done you know cuz you
evolved from necessity we've like run
out of necessity even if Apple never
comes out another update
we're like Phi I don't know how to grow
food and that's been fine the whole time
in fact ever I go the food was nice
enough to kill itself before I got there
be seasoned and not have a face so if
we're going to evolve from this point on
like as and I mean as a species not just
our stuff this is cool stuff it's the
best stuff in the history of stuff but
we're going to evolve as humans then
it's really up to women to keep humanity
honest cuz we're the only species where
the females mate with the weak
we're the only one if a deer slipping
into the woods all the dough's aren't
like but I love him they let that die
they let it die every time there's no
four leg broken bailing you guys want to
play cuz usually I do it alone
that's only humans humans the only ones
are like oh my guys gonna art school
he's trying no let it go that's how you
get me do you want more me you want more
guys we gotta go see Green Lantern I
heard good thing it's like no one needs
that and I'm not trashing a man in here
I had to return a jar of pickles at
Trader Joe's I couldn't open it so I
know
I know I'm not high on the list to make
new people it's just what has to happen
- sometimes I get on Facebook as I don't
care about being happy
does it bother anybody else that there's
no bottom there's no bottom you can
scroll until you die there's no bottom
[Applause]
and you're never done you never finish
Facebook you're just like you're either
gets so mad that you get off or you
realize you're late those are the only
two ways to get on and but I've noticed
this disturbing trend it's really
upsetting me where people online on
Facebook are being called racist now but
for like actually nothing like I'll read
the whole thread cuz I'm petty so I'll
read the post and then get to the bottom
and be like I don't think that's a thing
you know and I've noticed there's a lot
of like white people calling other white
people races and I'll just tell you as a
black dude they grew up in the south
I don't think you're racist until you go
to your second Klan meeting all right
hear me out
because maybe the first one maybe your
friend Dale's invite you a barbecue
everybody loves barbecue alright you get
there there's a delicious barbecue
there's dry rib they're sloppy it's all
happening
you see somebody putting on white hood
you're like I know it's a costume
barbecue that's a little odd but you
keep eating okay and there's corn on the
cob there's yams mashed potatoes it's
all happening then there's a burning
cross improving you're like I'm already
here I say this because I have my friend
Jordan he accidentally went to a Klan
rally and he didn't know what to do he
was like I ate all the food I can't miss
the meeting turns out Klan rides don't
just start they ease you in with a
barbecue and then he left and he went
home he called me I came over to his
house we talked about it turns out a
Klan rally is exactly think Claire I was
like there were no spoilers there but
just past his head in the kitchen I
could see it - go play
and I was like Jordan Jordan Jordan are
those Klan ribs and he was like yeah and
I was like can I have some and it hurts
me as a black dude that grew up in the
south to say that the Klan makes the
best ribs I don't know what they're
doing I don't know kind of rub that is
who wouldn't know you can't taste racism
it's delicious this is the point runs
like I think you need to join I need
these every Sunday these are basic guys
I'm Josh Johnson thanks so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you